the realm
do you know what the realm is
it's the thousand blades of aegon's
enemies
a story we agreed to tell each other
over
and over till we forget that it's a lie
what's up ladies and gentlemen welcome
back for another game of thrones and a
song of ice and fire video
in this video i will be discussing
another one of the unsolved mysteries
from the final season of game of thrones
the reason why i'm making this video is
because of something i read in a recent
article written by john fallon
now what he wanted to know was how much
from game of thrones season 8 will be in
the winds of winter
as i'm sure most of you know by now the
game of thrones writers david
and dan famously sat down with george rr
martin so they could discuss
how he would end his books they said
they needed to know where his story was
heading so they could start setting
things up in the show
that would essentially make sure they
end the same way although they may
go in drastically different directions
before they got there
unfortunately we may never find out
everything george rr martin said during
that meeting but one thing we do know is
he revealed three shocking events that
would happen before it all ended
we eventually found out what some of
these shocking events were
for those of you who don't know the
first shocking event was when stannis
baratheon had melisandre burn his
daughter shireen
now we don't know exactly how this will
go down in the books but according to
the game of thrones writers david and
dan this was given to them by george rr
martin
the second shocking event was the hodor
revelation
that was when hodor was sacrificed as
bran and mira escaped from the three out
ravens cave
again we don't know exactly how this
will happen in the books but dan and
dave said this was directly from george
himself
so that only leaves one more game of
thrones writer david benioff said the
final shocking moment
would happen at the end in the final
season as you all know it has now been
several years since game of thrones
aired its final episode yet dan and dave
still haven't revealed what that final
shocking moment was
we don't even know if they still went
forward with whatever information george
gave them
if they did show his third shocking
moment we may never know it was from the
books until we read them and find out
for ourselves
now let me show you what else david
benioff said during this interview
because it is very interesting
right after he said the final shocking
moment would be at the very end of game
of thrones he also said
fans were discussing whether the books
would be spoiled
he also said that's not exactly accurate
so much of what happens in the show
already diverges from the books and
while there are certain elements that
will be the same
we're not going to let you know how much
is actually from the books and i don't
think george is either
fans will be very surprised when they
read the books after the show
they're very different in so many
respects for the remainder of the show
it does seem like they stuck by this
statement after they revealed shireen's
burning and hodor's death were the first
two shocking moments they never gave us
any more additional insight into what
was actually from the books
now unless i'm forgetting something the
only other thing we can confirm from the
books is bran stark becoming the king in
the end
and if you remember this was not
revealed by david or dan
it was the actor isaac hempstead wright
who gave out this information during an
interview after the show was over
unfortunately the game of thrones
writers may never let us know what that
third shocking event
was but that doesn't mean we can't make
an educated guess
assuming they still did show it in the
final season
since david and dan said it would happen
at the very end we know it doesn't have
anything to do with what happened during
season 6 or season 7. if they did stick
to what george gave them
it should have happened in season 8. now
if you ask me
i think there are really only three
scenes in the final season you could
consider as shocking
as i go through the first episode in the
final season i don't notice any scenes
that i would consider shocking
everything that happens in this episode
is mostly set up for the next one
now samwell was certainly shocked when
he found out daenerys burned his father
and brother
but us as an audience already knew that
jon snow was certainly shocked when he
found out who his real mother and father
was
but once again us as an audience already
knew that as well
the episode ended on almost a very
interesting scene
when we saw the night king symbol
burning on the wall but as we all know
this basically amounted to nothing so
this would not be shocking either
the second episode of the final season
was mostly set up scenes as well
the episode did have arguably one of the
best scenes in the season
one brienne was knighted by jaime
lannister but i don't think any of us
would consider that shocking
now i do think daenerys was definitely
shocked at the end of the episode when
jon revealed he was aegon targaryen but
once again
us as an audience already knew this we
weren't shocked at all
the episode ended with a very exciting
scene as the night king's army arrived
just outside of winterfell but we knew
they would get there eventually
now this next episode may have at least
one scene that fans would consider
shocking but i will let you know why i
don't think it's the final shocking
moment
episode 3 is when the night king and his
army attacked winterfell
the battle did result in many of our
beloved characters getting killed but i
don't think any of these would be
considered shocking
we had been leading up to that battle
ever since the very first episode of the
very first season
everyone should have known many
characters would die if the white
walkers ever made it south of the wall
in fact there were some fans who even
expected everyone to die when that
happened but as we all know the night
king never made it any further
than winterfell he never even made it
out of the godswood because this is
where arya stark jumped from the foul
line to deliver her fatal blow
now this is a scene i could see fans
saying is the final shocking moment from
george rr martin
it was definitely very unexpected for
many of us fans including me
i don't believe this is the final
shocking event though the main reason i
think this is because there is not a
night king in the books
now some of you may say that's only
because he hasn't been introduced in the
story yet
and i actually think there will be a
night king in the books myself
he may not look like the one in the show
and he may not even have that same name
but i do believe there is a leader of
the white walkers in some form or
fashion
now with that said i still don't think
this is the third shocking moment
because i know this scene was not from
george
i know this is hard for some fans to
believe but david and dan have admitted
they created this scene on their own
they said it during an interview right
after the episode aired
they decided they would have arya kill
the night king about three years before
the final season was released
that would have been several years after
they had their meeting with george rr
martin
they manufactured that scene on their
own so since it was not from george i
know it's not the third shocking event
that he gave them
now if we go to episode 4 there are a
few scenes that could be in
consideration
daenerys's dragon rhaegal getting shot
out of the sky by euron was certainly
shocking
in the sense that no one thought it
would have happened that easily
especially after we are to believe danny
was so stupid she just kind of forgot
about the iron fleet
after hearing a statement like that i
know this scene had to be manufactured
by david and dan so i'm gonna go out on
a limb here and say
that's not the final shocking moment
from george either now there is one
other scene from this episode that i
think should be in consideration
and that is missandei's death i think
george might do something like this in
his books
although i think the way he has her
captured will be slightly different
this won't happen because dany forgot
about euron's fleet the reason why i
think we should consider missandei's
death as the final shocking moment
is because of who she is as a character
as well as who the other characters are
that were involved in the other shocking
moments actually think about who died
during those other events that were from
george rr martin
the first shocking event was the burning
of shireen in the second shocking event
was hodor's death
and or the revelation surrounding his
name
if there were any other characters who
did not deserve to die i think we can
make a good case for all three of these
characters
there weren't very many other characters
who are more innocent than them
now there are obviously a lot of other
characters who i wish did not die
like ned stark for instance i wish he
lived until the end
however i understand why he died the
same way i understand why daenerys died
their actions and their choices led to
their demise
shireen hodor and missandei however did
not do anything themselves that should
have led to their death
now i know they were always in the line
of fire because they were aligned with
one of the major houses that were at war
but they never did anything themselves
that harmed others
so i will say it again since shireen and
hodor were such innocent characters
maybe the third shocking moment involves
another character who fits that
description
with all of that being said i still
think there is one more scene that could
be considered
significantly more shocking than this
mostly because it had a much bigger
impact on the final season
in the fifth episode of the last season
there are a number of different scenes
that some may consider shocking however
i believe there is really only one that
stands above the rest
i don't think varys demise was shocking
at all because melisandre let us know
this would happen a full season
beforehand
i don't think jaime or cersei getting
killed was shocking either
if anything what did shock me about it
was the way in which they died
i was hoping for a much more gruesome
death for cersei or at the very least
dying at the hands or should i say hand
of jaime
that would have been very satisfying i
would not say there was anything
shocking about sandor
and gregor's final scene either this was
set up all the way back in the first
season not only that but the hound
reminded us over and over again how he
wanted to kill his brother
so i think most of us saw that happening
in the future
the one scene that did shock millions of
fans was when daenerys decided to burn
down king's landing with all of its
civilians
now the main reason why it may have
shocked as many fans as it did is
because of the execution
most would say her descent should have
happened a lot slower in the final
season
either way it was still a major event
that left millions of fans stunned in
the final episode of this season there
is at least
one more scene that makes the list one
of the biggest moments from the episode
is obviously when jon snow stabs
daenerys in front of the iron throne
i'm not sure if i would actually
consider this scene shocking because of
what dany did in the last episode
now if this happened without the last
episode i would definitely have been
shocked by it
but since daenerys burnt down king's
landing i felt like this almost had to
happen
as much as you might not agree with how
danny's story ended you should be able
to understand why someone had to stop
her
i know some fans like to say everyone in
king's landing deserve to die but i
don't agree with that whatsoever
there were children who died who had no
say in where they lived
i also know there are some who like to
say they deserve to die because some of
them were screaming for ned stark's head
but that was only a few hundred of them
daenerys set fire to hundreds of
thousands
most of whom were innocent that's why i
was not shocked when she died at the
end although i do agree her story should
have been handled
a lot better than it was there's no
doubt about that
the rest of this episode is somewhat
lackluster the only other scene that
should be considered is bran stark
becoming the king
that is another moment i know stunned
everyone i don't think anyone saw that
happening
and as much as i don't like it we all
know it is the one scene that did come
from the man himself
unfortunately this might have been the
final shocking moment
since it is the only one we do know will
happen in the books
not only that david benioff said it
would happen at the very end
now he could have just meant the final
season but if he meant the very end
as in the last episode this might be the
one
since it is the only scene that has been
confirmed as of right now
unless george r martin starts releasing
more books we may never actually find
out
and that would suck maybe just maybe
the final shocking moment were the
friends we made along the way
[Music]
[Music]
so
you